if you guys have heard
frank talk about the contemplative
fitness ai
um or bentino in his global
enlightenment retreat uses the analogy
of raindrops on windshield
as you're in the car is that you kind of
become sensation proof
so rather than having the sensation
trigger a conditioning of separate self
rather it's that windshield wiper or
this
contemplative fitness ai that's
constantly running where their
gap between a sensation
coming and you recognizing
how empty the sensation is
is immediate it's immediate you
recognize that
it's all coming empty right away so
there's no
when you get to the really high levels
that there's no
even possibility even any
for it to come and create a
elevation of a conditioned contracted
identity you you ultimately that's this
what we're talking about getting to
sensation proofing yourself would you
like to also
unpack this a bit for us frank yeah
so i'm just going to read a post that i
wrote because after i write something
down
i don't really think about anymore so if
i yes
if i summarize it i'll be all over the
place is it on your instagram can i pull
it up
uh it's in my i posted on my story but
um i
didn't make a post out of it so i don't
think you can see it right now but i
think it's
one of uh my highlights but i'll just
read it
yes i think the most direct and clearest
way to put all those different stages
of development in labels that we've been
talking about
under context is the direct realization
the nature of sensations now think of
sensations
as the atoms of your subjective
experience
both inside and outside what a meditator
or a contemplator does is consuming into
deconstruct and dissecting
and dissolving and shred your reality
into sensations at the microscopic level
all sensations are aware of themselves
exactly where they are
all sensations are devoid of full cell
with a small ass
and solve for the capital s and
spontaneously and codependently arising
all sensations are in equal footing
so no sensation cause or own
another cluster of sensations different
vibratory velocity of sensations
gives rise to the difference between
conical air
liquid and solid forms and all
sensations
self-liberate so sensations could be
anything from
body sensations to emotions to sight
sounds
uh emotions thoughts
basically your entire field of
experience is made up of sensations
so all sensations are non-dual as in
sensations
in and themselves can't tell the
difference between
god poop awareness consciousness
emptiness eternity
love intentions matter mind being sober
or be psychedelic or being
drunk time space etc etc
and since there is only clinical one
substance there is no difference
between the foreground and the
background this is where we talk about
deconstructing all the different stages
and deconstructing even the background
between the context and the contents
right because all sensations are
homogenous therefore phenomenons
do not arise and pass into some source
that is more clinical real and permanent
[Music]
now the labeling of these sensations and
the labeling of these phenomenons
into concepts as you guessed it just
more sensations
you start to see that even concepts are
sensations
even labels are sensations no different
from the things that they're labeling
so you don't get attached to even
concepts so what's the difference
between the awakened state
in the egoic state now this is very
important
in the former the knots of perception is
forever untied
in the awakened state because the nature
of sensations
is penetrated permanently and
experientially
now all sensations in your entire field
of experience
lights up and are aware of themselves
without a delay
between the subject and an object
between the perceiver
and the perceived observer and then
observe the witness and the witnessing
and this is your moment-to-moment
experience of the clinical godhead of
infinity of eternal awareness
because when sensations are experienced
without a doer controllers here here
thinker all 360 degrees panoramic
are known and comprehended as itself
without the delay between this or that
thus reality feels omniscient
in the egoic state certain cluster of
sensations arise in the center of
experience
usually inside the head being behind the
eyes and in place
in some place inside the body that's
hijacking other clusters or sensations
to clinical take credit for other
clusters of sensations in the field of
experience
and this is all due to conditioning
that's why we talk about observer
being trapped in an observer because
it's taking credit for uh
reality when this happens there's a
contraction of energy
when awareness or the ego is trying to
you know hijack
other fields or sensations to be my
there's a contraction of energy and
that's identification
that's the feeling of meanness that's
where the source of separation comes
from
that's it so when you zoom
experiences down to the atomic level
with next effort contraction like the
pasture
where you can no longer divide it this
singularity
ultimately loops back to the other side
like a strange loop
it becomes infinitely expensive that's
the difference between
you know the contraction method of the
passionate versus the do nothing
meditation
we simply just relax and let infinite
consciousness
uh return to its most natural state so
all those practices
merges one expansion and contraction
this is why the practice starts out as
dissecting atoms but at the end you end
up
repatriating the whole universe the very
small
is identical to the very large like the
merging of
quantum mechanics and cosmology love and
death at the subjected level
the parts is the whole and vice versa
the atom is the universe
now you can get to the same point either
by contraction or expansion
now we talked about that uh and also you
can you know
do some psychedelic trips have glimpses
of this or
do the contraction expansion method you
know while
uh you are under the influence of
psychedelics uh but
you know i mean in my own path uh all my
insights and
realizations came naturally i mean i've
experienced it with psychedelics in my
my 20s and have a few dmt trips but the
reason why i advocate being doing it
naturally
is because i'm just biased
because i i i i give my naughty man all
the credit
anyway so i think that's pretty much it
that was so good
um wait there's another one last part
yeah so when you take to the end point
contraction and expansion
uh just lose meaning and this is when
absolute infinity and absolute
nothingness
uh emerge simultaneously and this goes
back to what i was saying about how
uh the natural state is like a permanent
succession the unconsciousness
of uh nibana or the 9th jhana
but also infinite consciousness of the
sikh genre
now if if you don't see clearly the
nature of sensations
at all levels as being empty and full at
the same time
and not solve one particular level is
always going to seem more or less real
or solidified than another level that's
why
you started to identify with awareness
or consciousness or this or that gossip
because the sensations hasn't been seen
through so one level is
always going to be more solidified right
so that's when again contraction occurs
identification takes place
that's cleaning and suffering no
so if you understand sensation at the
experiential level
that's it but there's some pitfalls to
this as well
so the contemplative fitness ai enables
cessation at the experiential level yeah
and understanding sensation at the
experiential level
and understanding cessation of the
experiential level enables the
master resides in dao the natty state
perpetual
yes but but here's a but i was posting
this on a forum
and then there were some responses
saying this is
by deconstructing experiences only down
to the microscopic
level of sensations can be a little bit
uh
reductive it's almost like a scientist
who only cares about atoms
which i don't disagree with because i've
seen a lot of people that are really
into the view position in the past at
all
about sensations they see every
experience and just reduce it down to a
microscopic level of sensations
and they're they're more in the
emptiness side of the equation then the
love the infinity and the fullness side
but my
counter argument is for those people
they haven't taken sensations all the
way that's why there's a problem if you
take sensations
all the way like i said it loops back to
infinity
maybe you're taking sensations down to
the 99 percent level
but 99 in 100 percent is quantum
once you deposited sensation down to the
microscopic level and
100 you dissolve everything boom it's
absolute infinity
which is same as absolute nothingness
yeah so that's why you can get to the
same endpoint by
either doing vipassana in the theravada
path or by doing
uh sort of the zo chain kind of
practices like do nothing the stop
the saba version of the ocean because no
change is foolish for me it's the
natural state
but there's some versions of it where
you can do the awareness of awareness
practice abiding in consciousness kind
of practice like
the later former genres kind of practice
if you do that long enough
you also lose back to the to the
microscopic level
yeah but there are i see a lot of people
that sort of
lean towards one side of the of the
duality of the
equation which is really interesting
some people are more energetic they talk
about love a lot
you know and then they the way their
vibe is is like you know
more more in touch with the christ
consciousness and bodhisattva path
and some people are more into the
emptiness path if you take
this all the way
you merge the two you do you merge the
two if you take this
all the way this is this is what
this is it take this all the way this
contemplative fitness ai
take it all the way to see sensations at
this
most subatomic level if you do that
you will recognize what we're talking
about
which is being sensation proof and
enabling you to reside in life
itself to dissolve into life [ __ ]
itself
endlessly yes one more point so what
exactly is the natural statement
the natural the natural state is just
the fact that
once you see through how all sensations
are in equal footing
once you're not attached one club once
one cluster of sensation isn't hijacking
other cluster sensations all sensations
appear exactly where they are
as it is okay i have a question would
this
would this be like today
i'll go through this example and then
we'll go to the next
equanimity okay would this be this i
feel like this is gonna funnel perfectly
into this example
today the the trash service
came and the
other tenants in the building had been
emptying some food and drink and what
not into the bin
so it had created a very big stench over
the week
so i'm bringing the trash bin back after
it's already been emptied by the garbage
truck i'm bringing it back to the house
and i'm realizing that i'm gonna be
washing
the bin out and as i'm washing the bin
out
i realize that washing the dirty
garbage bin that smells rancid is the
exact same made of the same empty
in full infinitude as having sex
or drinking tea or watching hummingbirds
is that okay yeah it's just it's just
how everything is just made up of
how scientists will tell you
everything's made of atoms you know your
god experience is made of atoms so is
your uh
your poop right and sensation is just
observing
and realizing this at the experiential
and the subjective
level so you don't cling on to any
particular state
the ego state if the ego state is just
thinking that all one cluster sensation
is more real more solidified because you
haven't
seen through it that's contraction if
the state of
awareness becomes this new class of
sensations that you
um get solidified then that's also just
another degree
it's another degree that's transcended
from the ego state but if
if there's any preference over any
cluster of sensations
in your field of experience then you
cannot enter a state of
perfect equanimity that's it that's it
when there is no identification with
anything at all sensations can just
appear by
spontaneously simultaneously they're all
co-dependent rising
and they just appear as they are
spontaneous dependent origination
without a contracted conditioned
separate self to have preferences
right right and this preference could be
ice cream or infinite consciousness
yes an attachment to those preferences
which then creates the
craving aversion suffering yeah yeah
that's pretty much what the natural
state is okay beautiful so let's have
you continue defining this for us
like with here when in the dark so we
kind of talked about this
permanent cessation while conscious